[Musique]
c'est une structure qui accompagne des
entrepreneurs qui veulent innover dans
l'alimentaire on les accompagne de deux
manières la première c'est en leur
mettant à disposition des équipements
donc une cuisine expérimentale des
laboratoires et tout un banc
d'équipements professionnels pour
avancer dans leur test et la deuxième
manière de les accompagner c'est de les
mettre en relation avec tous
l'écosystème d'AgroParisTech donc d'une
part les étudiants avec des projets
notamment étudiants et d'autre part avec
tous les experts qu'on peut trouver dans
les unités de recherche d'AgroParisTech
typiquement ici on est dans une cuisine
expérimentale c'est un des lieux dans
lesquels les startups peuvent venir
travailler leurs produits faire leurs
recherches et développement
le footing Lab on accompagne des projets
très variés qui touchent à
l'alimentation durable ça peut être des
projets qui travaillent des alternatives
à la viande ou des nouvelles protéines
donc des algues des insectes des
légumineuses ce genre de produits ça
peut être aussi le développement de
nouveaux aliments à partir de co-produit
donc des anciens déchets qui jusqu'à
maintenant étaient pas utilisés et qui
sont valorisés pour des nouveaux
ingrédients
[Musique]
les entrepreneurs qu'on accompagne ici
sont au tout début de leur aventure
entrepreneuriale donc ils sont vraiment
un moment où ils vont faire des tests
pour trouver leur innovation développer
leur premier prototype ensuite il y a
toute une phase de recherche et de ce
qu'elle up pour monter à l'échelle et
pouvoir produire en quantité suffisante
pour commercialiser mais déjà à la
sortie du food in Lab ils sont en
capacité de faire des premières
productions et de vendre et puis les
réseaux de distribution dépendront des
produits ça peut être un e-commerce ça
peut être dans de la grande distrib ça
peut être dans des magasins spécialisés
en B2B etc
aujourd'hui l'avantage du Food Inna par
rapport à d'autres cuisines
expérimentales qu'on peut trouver dans
Paris par exemple c'est d'être connecté
à tous l'écosystème d'agropariste et de
pouvoir solliciter ces expertises et
maintenant qu'on est implanté sur le
plateau de Saclay c'est encore plus de
réseau de partenaires et d'expertise qui
peuvent solliciter facilement
[Musique]